[Music]
hey folks
welcome back to the dark horse podcast
live stream
q and a 66 still
still 66.66 gosh it seems like we were
just here
all right we uh we did a long stream
today we're going to try to keep it on
track for the questions so we can uh get
to a bunch of them
yep oh boy the dog just sneezed on my
leg that happened yeah right
yep hey tesla you know that uh the cream
is actually
back there i don't know
we have chaos should i should i help him
out or should i just let him figure it
out yeah
we'll figure it out okay he's going to
change the questions
well not his best move okay
what so we we are going to start with
four questions from last time and then
go to the discord question and then
launch into the man you guys asked a ton
of good questions this week
i will pick some of them up next week
but but
but we won't get through all of them as
usual what are your best news sources
for science-related reporting
have you ever considered being a part of
starting a news outlet that does science
reporting better for the sake of science
and the public
uh let me take that uh first i will say
first i thought wow i have no idea and
then i realized actually
um that uh both nature and science the
journals which are
you know imperfect for sure but that
they have
news sections so you know they they have
their sections where they are publishing
the peer-reviewed
literature and these are considered the
two most uh esteemed science journals in
the world but they also have news and
every week
you don't have to be a subscriber or
have institutional
support to get their weekly
journals you can get the table of
contents delivered to your inboxes every
week
and science for instance has it this
week in science
and best pics or something over what
it's called but basically
they have people there looking through
the other literature
basically basically the papers that they
probably got sent and they rejected and
they were published somewhere else
and then they're like hey that's sort of
interesting let's report on that here so
um i religiously read those every week
um and there's other places too but
that's probably the
big source for me in terms of where i
look where i find
um you know breaking research that is
that is of interest it's funny that you
say you read them religiously
i'm imagining that richard dawkins is
shaking his fist at us right now
yeah yeah and then you know have you
ever considered uh
being a part of starting a news outlet
that does science reporting better for
the sake of science and the public
yeah sure um yeah we have and uh you
know it's not exactly
the uh the province of the um
consilience project but it's close and
we are uh in discussions with those
folks so
in any case um i would say there's a
problem
with uh science news which in part has
to do with the fact
that um a lot of scientific conclusions
aren't true and so the most important
thing is not so you're not talking about
the separate publication that's called
science news
no you're talking about i'm talking
about how to read news of the scientific
sphere which is to say
with um plenty of grains of salt you
have to
so you know i i don't assume that any of
these little news reports in science or
nature are accurate
um you know a you can't assume that the
paper is what it claims to be
but you certainly can't assume that the
reporting on what the paper claims
is accurate so you you know one of the
one of the benefits unlike say the new
york times
um so you know we talked about this this
sidewinder paper
that i i found that first in the new
york times this week
but it was ridiculous how difficult it
was to figure out what paper they were
talking about they said things like
the author's name in one place and where
she was located another place and where
it was published another place
and approximately when but didn't give
co-authors didn't give a title
and it was actually incredibly difficult
to find
and that's something that the more
standard news outlets do a poor job of
whereas the reporting on recently
published research
in an actual scientific journal will
always be at least perfect about that
about showing you where to go to find
the actual research
so i would say i i tend to read with a
lens
of um what if that were true
right and then i sort of follow it
through and sometimes uh it will lead
you
oh actually that would make a great deal
of sense if that were true and sometimes
it leads you to a great deal of
skepticism and then you only really know
what you think about it when you
see what the thing is based on and
whether it was well done but
anyway grains of salt yeah
next question every spring a bird makes
a nest under the deck by my apartment
door in the exact same spot
eggs get stolen so why does the bird
keep coming back and how does it know
exactly where it was before
so two two actually very different
questions right how does the bird know
exactly where it was before
how do you know where your apartment
door is it's gonna be
a very similar answer and yes we're not
birds and
um and you know we've got more
complexity and actually bird kind of
complexity
is convergently evolved to mammal kind
of complexity and obviously humans
um take that complexity a few steps
farther than other mammals but
um it shouldn't be surprising to us that
uh especially a social bird can find its
way in the world and has a map by which
to navigate
any more than we're surprised when we're
able to do it yep i'm a little
surprised by the report that the animal
keeps returning even though
it sounds like all of the eggs are
stolen yeah now that that sounds like an
accident
yeah i mean i mean i didn't mean
accident mistake it sounds like
a bird dodo you know they're extinct
right
no dodo birds are extinct a bird dodo is
just a
bird who doesn't get it yeah yeah yeah
now obviously birds who do that don't
leave
descendants so um that behavior to the
extent that it is genetically heritable
uh doesn't persist
yeah i wonder how many instances of that
you've seen
um yeah and you know it is possible too
unless you are um banning the birds or
have a really good eye for the
inter-individual variation
in birds that it's a different
individual the same species and that the
spot
seems by all the usual rubrics that
whatever species it is you don't specify
use to be a really great nesting spot
but it turns out it's really not because
someone say it's a raccoon
um you know knows that there's often a
nest there and will always come and
steal the eggs so it could be that it's
not the same bird making the
the same mistake over and over again
which really wouldn't persist in
evolutionary time
but rather there's something else about
um it's tucked away from the wind from
sight from whatever that it looks
uh for a season at least like it'll be a
good choice turns out not to be that
bird never comes back but
it looks exactly as good to a what's
called a naive bird a bird that hasn't
experienced the losses
as it did to the previous naive birds
yep
hey brett heather just wondering if you
guys knew anything about lasik surgery
or any other refractive correction
surgery
how safe are they really i feel like i
may have talked about this at one point
on some form or q
a yeah i like it too i don't i don't
remember
um where though so um i will say super
briefly
i was actually scheduled to have lasik
i've got incredibly strong myopia
like negative seven diopter for those of
you who know those sorts of numbers
and um the prospect of actually being
corrected so that i could do things like
play sport
and go into the field and not be totally
reliant on my
corrective lenses was uh was remarkable
and i ended up with a a fungus in my eye
that i picked up from a long field
season in madagascar which caused the
surgery to be delayed
i had scheduled it for shortly after i
got back from this long field season
and um in my frustration i did a bunch
more research about what
lasik actually was the fact is i don't
know long term i suspect
that the outcomes aren't quite as clean
as people are saying but i don't know
in terms of risks what i do know is that
at least at that point and this is
boy 15 18 years ago at this point um
that it turns out that anything to
2040 or 2050 or better even if it wasn't
further correctable with corrective
lenses was considered a success
and um if you have ever walked around
being able to see
things having to be twice as close as
anyone else to be able to see them with
clarity
which is what 2040 would be um you know
that that is not
actually perfect vision and you can't
actually
navigate a jungle safely that way or
play
a team sport with fast moving objects
effectively it would effectively turn
you into someone
who suddenly had a sensory disability
when before you just had
a a kind of disability that was
correctable so
i opted not because um
fully corrected from lasik surgery turns
out not to mean what most of us would
regard as fully corrected
yep this
is oh this is just a um i don't know if
you've heard about this so
dr drew pinsky started something called
the rational revolution
you did it first but the more rational
people the better maybe a
non-traditional collaboration could be
in the works
thank you for all you do all the best do
you know anything about this
nope okay so um yeah so i've actually
got that highlighted
um we've got a lot of stuff to come back
to so i don't know if we will but
um thank you for the for pointing that
out
okay so this is from the discord server
this week
i usually have a few colds per year but
i haven't had any since the first
lockdown in spring last year
i have been masking and disinfecting
when appropriate is there any downside
to having such a prolonged period of
inactivity for the immune system
is there any downside conceivably there
is some downside but i don't think it
could come
anywhere near the upside that there
clearly is
so you know let's put it this way we can
make an
argument that you will carry immunity
away from these little interactions that
you have which will make you
uh susceptible to them if you encounter
these bugs in the future so you could
kind of make a weak argument for
the benefit of you know it's like
taking pride in collecting immunological
information in your system but you're
much better off just never having had
these bugs and if you get them later
then you'll pick up the immunity so
i would say don't question it stay away
from these bugs capacity for adaptive
immunity doesn't decline
right the the exposure um
the the fact that you might have a
slight head start on something
should you be exposed in a larger dose
will
not exist but the capacity to develop
adaptive immunity
does not decline just because your
immune system has spent a year not
mostly being exposed to yeah it wouldn't
be that it will decline a little bit
because you'll be older
um but i would just say you know the
thing that we never
talk about is that all of these uh
diseases that have symptoms have
symptoms because they're doing tissue
damage
and that tissue damage has a cost that
we don't typically measure
and so you know you you in theory have
the capacity to live
to 120 years of age you won't you won't
because you will even
encountered all sorts of things to
damage you along the way and burned up
some of the capacity that you would have
needed to be present
in order to get to 120 and if we turned
the dial in favor of more repair
capacity then you'd probably die much
earlier of cancer so anyway those two
things have been balanced but the basic
point is look
if you can avoid the damage that comes
with being sick and the downside is that
you might get sick with that thing
later there might be a tiny little extra
cost to being sick with it later
on the other hand if you get hit by a
bus tomorrow then
you weren't sick ahead of time and you
got away with it
so anyway i would say i think the answer
you're looking for
is no it's a slam dunk win
right does that mean that if we analyze
the downside in isolation
that it's zero it's not zero it might be
something but it's going to be tiny
relative to the upside go with it
stay healthy and to the extent that you
can learn the lessons of
2020 and 2021 and figure out how never
to get these
diseases in future cold seasons
uh all the better yep
so this is a few this is like
five questions three from one person and
then two others that are all
kind of related so i'm going to read
them all before we respond
um the the first two from someone other
people
are um have you read the time.com
article yet
yes and speaking of media pieces have
you read the time magazine article about
the conspiracy to fortify the election
their words not mine i've heard a fair
amount of the thoughts on it but i very
much like to hear yours
and then a three-part art came in in
three parts
i tried to give my all to unity 2020 but
i knew it was
i knew it was a long shot had i known
that a collective of this magnitude was
working against everything but the
proper outcome i would have applied a
different tactic
if time is saying this then the overton
window has slid so far
that if popular opinion no longer
represents the reality that i see
day to day i pray that the left of
center this and has the courage to
say something um
oh by the way these donations are my
birthday gift to myself this year
please keep up the good work bretton
heather keep being a voice of the
traditional parentheses question mark
left godspeed so i have not read this
article this these all
these all are referencing something that
i have not read but you have
yeah well i will say i read it quickly
and i should probably go back through it
it was simultaneously um jaw-dropping
and maddening and in another way
no news so in a sense i have the feeling
that the important thing about it is
what
isn't in it right in other words it
describes a
an organized effort to
do what they euphemistically call uh
fortify the election something like that
um
is that their language i think so anyway
we had a discussion about it
um quite a good discussion about it on
on clubhouse last night and i thought
that discussion went very well with an
earlier discussion with justin amash
about his experience in congress which
is
always revealing he knows things about
what's wrong with our congress that most
of us even those of us who pay attention
don't know
and so anyway this is the larger
conversation that has to happen but
the basic point about the time article
was that the time
article admits to
a kind of collusion that i think marches
right up to the limits of what the law
will allow maybe in one place it
treads a bit that's it um so you want to
show this what dad's talking
so it describes this organized effort to
make sure
that you know in light of what they
expected to go
wrong with trump not ceding power blah
blah blah blah blah
that they did all of these things
including changing election laws
basically they acknowledge a um
collusion uh in order to
make sure as they describe it that the
election turns out properly but the
point is actually
what they describe is completely
consistent with them
going well beyond what the law allows
and feeling justified in doing it and
most importantly
demonizing those of us who were
skeptical of their
motives and willingness to
break rules etc etc so you know look
on the one hand your system is
completely corrupt
it just is and this is not surprising
it's
weird that the article exists and you
know there's some question as to
why the article exists does it exist to
create
um smoke so that we don't see something
much more frightening that may have
happened
we don't know all we know is that
there's this article in which they say
yeah we engaged in all this collusion to
make the right thing happen in the
election right
um so anyway um
it's it's hard to know what to think
about it i do think one wants to think
about it in the context
of okay here's what's in the article
what isn't in the article
and what did you do to people who um
didn't believe that the election was uh
just a straightforward exercise in
democracy
and you know do you owe them an apology
etc but
um they're all domestic terrorists
aren't they
yeah so anyway i'm not sure what to say
about it yeah
yes these people suck and they have
corrupted your system and they own both
parties
and uh you should expect them to do
anything that they can get away with and
it's long overdue
that we hold them to account and uh
rescue our system
from their absolutely diabolical sense
that
they know what's right and wrong and
that democracy would be too dangerous to
to allow or something like that yep
um two related questions here hello
heather i think i heard you say maybe
back in november that there is a proper
way to do astrology but it isn't done by
people who practice astrology
if i heard you correctly what did you
mean by that and then uh
secondly per your hypothesis more
complex astrology charts do in fact take
into account the hour
minute and location of one's birth not
just day and year
as these are needed to calculate the
relative positions of the planets in the
various quote-unquote houses
so what what i said and what's actually
in our book
is um that astrology is easy to mock
because
the way that it's done by and large the
way that most of us run into it to the
extent that we do
is is patent garbage right it's it just
it can't it can't be true um and
furthermore i would say you know the
idea that
the um what is it hour and minute of
your birth right that's proof that the
correction isn't the correction
um is it can't can't make any difference
but uh what what i said and there's a
paper that i
can't pull up right now because i don't
have it i don't have it pulled up but
it's it's referenced in our book and um
i can i can talk about another time um
what i said was it will probably be true
that the combination of when you are
born
in the year at sort of a seasonal level
not to the minute level but
at a seasonal level in combination with
where you are born
is likely to have developmental effects
because
being born for instance in the middle of
a minnesota winter
versus in the middle of an arizona
summer
and actually those two might actually be
surprisingly similar in terms of
oh you're you're locked up in close
quarters you may be more prone to
respiratory diseases precisely because
you're in
in small places in the north because
it's too cold in the south because
you're in ac all the time that
that combination of where and when may
well
have effects on
disease ideology and also if that
why not also on personality and there is
a really big retrospective paper
um looking at gosh i think it might have
even been like
hundreds of thousands although again i i
don't want to say that for sure
of of patients of of data at some
massive hospital in new york
that indeed was able to correlate for
that hospital so it's one spot so
they've kept the location constant
and they've looked at the rate of um
the risk of disease as these people grew
up all having been born into this
hospital
and it is many of these diseases um
vary significantly by month in which
they were born
that there are some months in which you
can be born where you were much more
likely you know
you know at least in this particular
paper um some months in which you can be
born
in new york where you are much more
likely as an adult to
end up with heart disease versus mood
disorders
uh if you're born at some other month so
we know that is true
and that seems to me um to be uh
clearly suggestive that if if you did
astrology
right which um you know again the fact
that people are looking at hour and
minute of birth that i cannot begin to
fathom what hypothesis gets you to like
it's
nonsense to that makes sense um but
but there can be some um something to
the idea that if you know
when you were born and where you were
born you might be able to predict
something about
how you will be so what i want to say is
there may be some ancient tradition of
astrology that accidentally happens into
this
area and has nonsense explanations or
metaphorical explanations for patterns
that doesn't mean there's some way to do
astrology right
the only thing that we are saying is
that it would not be surprising if
people
could be broken into cohorts based on
when they were born and where they were
born that had predictive
consequences and the way to see this is
let's imagine that we compare not
somebody from minnesota to somebody in
arizona but somebody in
arizona to somebody in sydney right
what is the prediction of the fact that
somebody
frankly i know so little about
astrological signs and when they come i
can only use my own which i happen to
know
right so you know pisces is born
in late february and
that pisces is born in the middle of
winter
in arizona and in the middle of summer
in uh in sydney it may predict exactly
the opposite things of what personality
would flow
from that interaction with the world so
the point is you can't say a pisces has
these characteristics you might if you
lived in one place and everybody else
lived in that place notice
characteristics you could conceivably
come up
with a pattern that would be detectable
and that pattern would break
if you moved within the first three
months of your life
the pattern would be very noisy for
those reasons
and you know to the extent that you said
hey i've noticed this pattern and you
wrote about it and you
emailed it and emailed it you mailed it
to somebody
in some different locality then the
point is
uh chances are that unless the locality
is pretty similar
it you know it will break and to the
extent that you don't notice that
everything is inverted as you cross the
equator
you you screwed up yeah yeah so zach you
can just show my screen i did
i did pull up the paper i was talking
about it's from 2015
uh boland at all birth month effect
affects lifetime disease risk a
phenome-wide method and
yeah they look at 1 million 749 000 400
individuals
that is to say records um from new york
presbyterian and columbia university
medical center
people born between 1900 and 2000 so
pretty amazing um
data set that they look at um and uh
yeah maybe that's all for that
yeah that's an amazing data set but you
would expect that from virgos
[Music]
nice thank you very good
um let's see
uh this one uh this person wants to
answer so badly that they asked it twice
uh in different parts of the of the
super chat can you please help me
understand why you support the paris
climate accord
it seems to be a mostly virtue signaling
measure as goals are self-selected and
unenforced is it symbolic or substantive
and able to make a difference
yeah you're nodding yes frankly you know
as i said
i'm not hopeful of the paris accords
actually do anything
worth doing what i'm interested in is
that
all nations participate in
a discussion about how to govern the
global commons with respect to
ocean's atmosphere etc so
it is just simply the re-establishment
that we are part of the community of
nations
and that we could be brought into an
agreement in which we all
did our share to rein in runaway
processes of which i do think
climate change is one um but no i have
no
particular fondness for the paris
accords and i remember
when they were initially signed rolling
my eyes and thinking
um you know that isn't going to
work not nearly sufficient so
nothing special about those accords just
the participation in the community of
nations is really what it is
great is there an evolutionary
explanation for
near-death experiences love to you both
from canada
were we just talking about yeah we were
just talking
um yes i believe there is
a very interesting explanation and
i i promise you
somehow in the next year it's going to
fit in
with the other things that i am holding
back and want to deliver in some form
other than deeply buried in a q
a but let's just say um
you ought to think not only about the
experiences
of those who get very close
to death but you ought to think also
about their loved ones
um that's all i'm going to say but yes i
believe there's a perfectly rigorous
evolutionary hypothesis to be tested and
i'm very hopeful that it will turn out
to be true
and my guess would be if it is true that
it will change
the way we address end of life
it actually it materially alters what
the right thing to do with a dying
person is yeah
that's good i was talking with a friend
the other day
about how a male's purpose has changed
he argued because times are more
peaceful many have harder times finding
meaning
what is the validity of that statement
um i well
i don't want to compare as between males
and females because i think this moment
is so
uh distorting of purpose for almost
everybody and yes there are ways we
could focus
on um a particular
problem for males and i think some of
these problems are particular that there
were
you know honorable uh ways
for many different kinds of men to
contribute
um in the world and that now that we are
suddenly
demonizing masculinity itself that of
course anybody whose
strengths are in that neighborhood is
now suspect
um viewed as dangerous
and you know let's just be clear about
this it's a dangerous world
men have done the heavy lifting of
protecting
their populations and their nations for
all of
human history so that was a role
somebody could play
and a way that we understood people to
be contributing to our collective
well-being
and to the extent that this is a world
in which that doesn't necessarily add up
yes it has taken a large category of
meaning
and essentially almost eliminated it
from the map
yeah i um i concur with that um
and i guess i would say we several
months ago now
watched a series of basically war or
films and war worse stuff with our boys
starting with the series band of
brothers
and then we watched gosh five six seven
really excellent
movies mostly world war ii in vietnam
about world war ii in vietnam
and those in combination with you
haven't but
um i have in fact i've read one excerpt
here
both of sebastian younger's books he has
more than this but
war and tribe speak to
speak to what war
can do for men with regard to finding
meaning
and and and also you know community
which is a word that probably very few
soldiers use with one another but
um that there is um
certainly there has always been a role
for men in peacetime
but uh wartime has has provided
other roads to meaning and uh
and productivity really as well yep
yeah uh and this is a question i guess
for you know people who were
out there um which because it was in the
super chat some people will have seen
but
has anyone started holding live group
screenings i feel like i could be in an
outdoor theater of sorts and fresh air
and sun watching this with others in
real time
loose discussion to follow during
intermission much love
i love that idea that's great yeah i do
too uh oh
live group screenings like people
getting together to watch is that the
idea
yeah it's cool um yeah stay safe
outdoor i like uh yeah outdoor fresh air
yeah so i don't know maybe maybe a
suggestion um
to take to the discord um since that's a
place where people actually can
potentially hook up get together yeah
and it would be cool actually to
interact with such things if there was
some
level of organization yeah good idea
um and then this one actually you know
the the top donation this hour for which
we are grateful which i didn't see
um at first much love to you both from
the true north once strong and still
somewhat free
huge appreciation for showing up the
ramparts of nuance against bs
and then a secondary donation and one
for young zachary of course
great work sir thank you awesome thank
you
um and then this one as well uh big
donation i have made an extensive
attempt to explore the approach to model
building and subsequent behavioral
modification you are discussing here
especially with respect to managing the
breath
i invite your feedback please check
patreon messages
youtube won't let me link it here so i
will um
it's a very large donation i will link
that um it would be
useful to know which which patreon
patreon does not make it easy to
search through messages so if we have to
search through everyone's messages it's
it's it's like i try to go through all
of them and i don't get through all of
them and i know you
you don't you aren't able to there's a
particular problem where
uh somehow the interface does not allow
a response at least through the phone so
at the point that i
get these things i see them i write a
response and then it doesn't go through
and it's very very frustrating yeah the
phone the phone app for patreon is no
good
yeah it's really not um
thanks for clearing up the bear virus
origin story the bears have been doing
research in circuses for years without
being held accountable
interesting point thank you for
recognizing what we were actually
talking about yes i do hope there are no
more bears in circuses i like bears
yeah there's no way to live yeah
as a bear in a circus
i don't think being a bear is no way to
live no no being a bear is a great way
to live i'm told
but while the lab leak hypothesis is
gaining steam
uh still we hear the trope that there's
nothing about the viruses structure
itself that suggests it's man-made would
love to hear further thoughts
so this came in pretty early last hour
probably before we got to talking about
exactly this yeah
let's just say in short um
it depends what you mean by nothing in
the viruses structure
there are anomalous things in the
genetic information
in the genome they are things that could
be explained
through natural processes there are
things that could be explained
through known laboratory processes
and it is worth saying that
uh the barrick lab in fact
um created a
technique that they in fact officially
labeled
as noseem cuts
or no cm edits and so
the basic point is look the art of
altering uh genomes
so as to leave something that is as if
natural
is part of what is being attempted in
the lab
so you know i would say either you're
going to read into the sequence
and then there is evidence and it is not
conclusive or
you're not going to read into the
sequence and you're going to look for
some sort of gross
structural change which you are unlikely
to see
i think i think that's ah here you go no
cm sites
yeah so
so this is um this i think is a
pre-print i just i have not
i have not gotten through all of this
i'll scroll up and give you guys all
vertigo but um
it's a site i haven't have open
synthetic viral genomics risks and
benefits for science and society
written by ralph barrick at unc chapel
hill
2006 um and it's
it's long um but there's there's just
there's there's a lot of what appear to
be smoking guns in here
or at least gun smoke yeah maybe just
gun smoke
um okay there seems to be a penalty to
stating the obvious
regarding lab escape is this tabulation
of basic reason a more recent feature of
a modern culture or is there an
evolutionary component
there's an evolutionary component but
it's out of place so
in short i would say in most
circumstances
you want to be pretty much in
sync with what your population believes
that there's very little to be gained by
being out of step with your population
and you're very unlikely to change what
your population believes and so
more or less accepting the mythology of
your population is a good idea
scientists have to do the opposite right
the whole point of science is to
discover what we don't know
about the way things actually function
which means you have to be
a little bit deaf or maybe even a lot
deaf to what people
think they know so that you can see past
it and what's happened is
very normal human processes have been
allowed to contaminate science
and we no longer reward people in fact
we punish them
for being out of step with the
conventional wisdom which basically
causes science to be much more like a
rubber stamp of conventional wisdom
so something like that yep
two podcasts ago you mentioned that in
some animals that operate in three
dimensions like birds of prey females
tend to be larger than males
could you elaborate on the connection
between the two
yeah the connection is so imagine the
following selection
builds a creature to be
ecologically optimal and then it
distorts that creature
for reasons that matter a lot with
respect to fitness whatever fitness
exactly is and it's not exactly
reproduction but close enough in order
to get to reproduction
you can be distorted from your
ecological optimum
now in cases where
males and females are
monogamous the interests of males and
females tend to be quite
symmetrical and the force that distorts
one or the other tends to be small in
general it's going to be males who are
distorted
in cases where there is not monogamy and
there is therefore a large
prize in terms of many mates to be
gained by winning these competitions
the distortions can be very very large
so the
iconic example would be elephant seals
where males can be
many times i think it's six i've heard
up to 11 but let's say six times
the size of females i think certainly
the word distortion is apropos in the
case of elephant seals oh so distorted
yeah
um but in any case the point is the eco
ecological optimum looks a lot like a
female because a female
goes out into the world and does her
ecological thing and the distortion is
necessary for her to reproduce are small
right so she looks pretty close to the
ecological optimum the male
is wildly off that optimum in um
elephant seals in fact in elephant seals
he has a whole different ecology because
you can't feed a large body like that in
the same
niche that the female is feeding a small
body like that so males go much farther
they
dive much deeper anyway it's a weird
system
but the key thing is if you're going to
compete in two dimensions
like an elephant seal who competes with
other elephant seals
on a beach on a rookery yeah so just to
be clear like they forage in three
dimensions but they compete
uh socially in two dimensions yeah
they're pretty much they're pretty much
solitary in three dimensions
males who are competing for harems bash
each other and uh
gouge each other on beaches that's
two-dimensional distorted like i said
yeah distorted but imagine that instead
of being in that two-dimensional plane
you were going to
engage in some sort of aerobatic battle
or
you know three-dimensional aquatic
battle then the answer is well being
bigger and burlier
might not pay and being smaller and more
agile
might pay and so the competition pushes
in exactly the opposite
direction it pushes in the direction of
um
you know of agility awesome
yeah yeah so much to say there but let's
let's move through
as someone with their bachelor's and
dietetics and bh and b
and phd in nutritional biochemistry and
i don't know if that stands for
physiology or physics nutritional
biochemistry and
physics or physiology i'm not sure which
i'm going to start over and just make up
a word
as someone with their bachelor's in
dietetics and phd in nutritional
biochemistry and fizz
physiology it's got to be i think so
probably i vouch for your current
positions on nutrition and disease
i also agree that more evolutionary
training and nutrition is needed
thank you excellent yes can you give us
the recipe for the cocktail the portland
mugshot
i mean we covered this i know right i
think i think our awesome clips guy dave
even clipped it
all right but i'll give you a little
review yeah if you need to have time
though
if you need more detail you can go back
to the clip but basically
you want to do this with as much care as
you can you place the mug
on a flat surface does it have to be
flat yes
it has to be level surfaced flat not so
much depending on the bottom of your
cup but you put the cup on a level
surface
one ounce of your hard alcohol of choice
put it in the bottom and then
that's it and you drink it yep yep
it's fancy yes it is men do like their
fancy drinks
oh yes absolutely there's no umbrella no
there's no it's a rain cone we'll fake
hawaiian grass or something
something okay um
you hear about the river that flooded
the garden of eden yeah god damned it
have you seen the u-haul documentary yet
it's moving
these are original dad jokes cecil
charles officials i appreciate you know
the thing is it takes us
i should have had you read them but yes
you weren't prepped it takes a certain
amount of courage to write down a dad
joke
because you know if you deliver a dad
joke and it doesn't go over you know it
dissipates if you don't remind people
then it doesn't come up in their memory
and it's lost
but yeah watch i'm like i'm highlighting
this
there's no way we're losing these you
got them there we go
yeah you got it dude yeah you're not
living this down yeah
um telling all telling evolutionary
biologists to stay in their lane
you should send them a photo of the
eight lane 405 freeway in la
those are all our lanes yeah yeah man
that's right yes yes i i frequently say
evolutionary biology is
licensed to transgress all disciplinary
boundaries
much to the irritation of almost
everyone pretty much everybody which is
delightful in its own right
yes you do find it so yeah um let us uh
what
what's the time zack you are at 40
minutes
40 minutes um let us switch and see how
many questions we've got
in the super chat at this point for this
hour and then maybe we'll come back this
we're missing a lot of them but
okay uh oh i'm okay another one at a
higher
um i work in the middle of western
australia as a lifeguard
forced to stay in the sun for long
periods of time should i not then
artificially adapt myself to be more
like the locals that is wear sunscreen
right should i not then artificially
should i not wear sunscreen oh well i
would say this is this is actually
pretty simple
um unfortunately for a lifeguard though
it's not
it's not totally without risk here's
what i would say the answer is
if you can behaviorally prevent yourself
from
getting sunburned then i would say
don't wear sunscreen you the last thing
you want
is sunburn sunburn is really really
dangerous
right now it's more dangerous the
younger you are that we know
um sunburns when you're young give you
cancer when you're old the older you are
when you get the sunburn the less it
matters
um for a couple different reasons but
and you have a little bit of that still
in the telomere paper right you left a
little bit of that stuff in
yeah it's there but anyway i would say
if you can behaviorally adjust so that
you don't need the sunscreen in order to
avoid the sunburn
that's better but if you're gonna get a
sunburn for trying to use behavior the
sunscreen is probably better
absolutely and by behaviorally adjust
you you mentioned this but it was so
fast in passing in the first
two hours today um what you i mean you
started proposing and you had our
children do and our children
have had almost no sunscreen on their
bodies and
um zach got a sunburn once on a field
trip as i remember a really bad one but
um but i think toby's never had one and
they've spent a lot of time outside in
the sun anyway
but the
okay zach says there's been some
sunburns i'm i'm gonna guess though that
many of those have been at camp when we
didn't we weren't overseeing it
um so um the behavioral modification
um that you started to have all of us do
was
um you know pick your periodicity it's
going to be different depending on what
your skin type is like you're more
you're way more prone to burning than
than i am for instance um but say
it's after 15 minutes in the sun with no
protection you know between the areas of
ten and two
at a place close enough to the equator
to really feel that um
you begin to feel you begin to feel in
any way warm
you find shade and you get yourself you
stay in the shade for
you know a third the amount of time or
something that you've been out there for
or you know maybe it only actually maybe
the refractory period is actually the
same period no matter how long you've
spent out
but you have to i find it's it it's in
order to be effective at this it's
actually relatively short breaks
can give you relatively long periods in
the sun yeah but you can't
skip one you can't skip one so like
maybe it's 20 or 30 minutes that you can
go you know depending on how early is in
the season what your
you know what your ancestors were and
you know how light your skin is all of
this
um how early in the season meaning both
like do you have
any you know any protection laid in this
season yet at all
and um and also how strong are the sun's
rays
um depending on how close to the
solstice it is um
but uh you know just so
rinse and repeat right like 25 30
minutes out in the sun make sure you
have a place to retreat to if as a
lifeguard you have
one of those huts i'm most familiar with
the ones from the socal beaches you know
if you have one of those places that you
can actually
be sitting in fully not in the sun when
you're not
actually doing a rescue then you
probably don't need
sunscreen yeah i would also say in my
experience at least
at the point where you feel like oh no
did i burn
right your skin is a little bit hot and
you feel like you may have
yeah but it still works the point is
it's actually substantially beyond that
the real burn starts you there is a
warning if you
um pay attention to it yeah
um all right we're going to switch and
there's zach's got a line for us
uh white house press secretary said even
after vaccines
we will have to mask in social distance
isn't the point of a vaccine that it
changes things for the better
that's our friend holly uh asking the
right questions
as she always does yeah i mean i have to
say i'm a little bit
cautious about this because i still
don't think we know where we are
with respect to covid and
yes ideally the whole point of the
vaccines
is to get us out of this mess
on the other hand we know very little
about you know
what happens downstream of these
vaccines we're going to start pushing
this virus around evolutionarily by
denying it access to people who've all
had the same vaccine which is going to
cause it to change and so you know
it's not it's not binary right yeah the
immunity
uh is valuable i'm not
saying that we won't have our trust
abused and be told
to you know to modify our behavior even
when it's not
epidemiologically necessary i think
that's a risk but it's not clear to me
that given how precarious things are
that
um you know i mean for one thing we
haven't even done the basics here
we don't know yet if the vaccines
actually block transmission
they seem to reduce symptoms in the
people who've had the vaccines and
hopefully
also the likelihood of them getting it
but if they have it
we don't have any evidence that it
blocks
uh transmission i think it would be
super surprising if it didn't
yeah like really really surprising but
um but
i think there's still no clinical
evidence for that but we also i mean we
haven't even talked about
whether or not it makes sense for people
who've had covid
to have the vaccine which you know
but this is another thing that just
being said well of course you need to
get the vaccine
right and um
i mean i can i can think of mechanisms
that would actually make it
counter-indicated and certainly there is
the unhedged risk
and there is every possibility that
having had covid
actually gives you the protection the
vaccine would give you anyway so it's
really unclear to me
especially in light of the fact that we
apparently have a problem with the
amount of vaccine
right right right there's all sorts of
arguments why we might want to at least
think twice
with respect to people who've already
been sick yeah no i'll just uh yeah i'll
say again that the
three groups that are easy for me to say
really be cautious
um like really consider not is children
no
pregnant women no and if you've already
had kovid
consider the risks with that information
as part of your risk assessment yes
with you know the wild card of
your you're triggering the immune system
with a protein your immune system is
already
primed to react to so
i mean you know just to just to be clear
about this
i'm not saying the following thing does
happen but i'm saying the following
thing
is plausible and therefore deserves to
be
eliminated as a possibility rather than
just assumed not to be a possibility
if you get a vaccine and it causes the
production
of spike protein in order to inform your
immune system but your immune system is
already primed
to react to that spike protein the spike
proteins that you produce
in order to create that reaction may gum
up
the cells of your immune system which
are primed to react to it and it could
make you
more prone to covet am i saying it
happens no or is it possible that it
could promote
an autoimmune response itself which is
always the danger here you're talking
about a system
either of those which are different
possible outcomes neither which is good
yeah
so uh in any case
i don't know how we ended up in this
ridiculous predicament but
here we are yeah um
fyi tim poole invited you guys live on
air to come to his show
this last week i didn't know that i
didn't know that
yeah um second if you go dark do you
have
alternate sites and contact lists great
work
um cool thanks for telling us about
um tim poole didn't did not know that
and you're the first person to tell us
um yeah we really should get more of our
ducks in a row
uh about um for instance at least being
on i don't even is it pronounced library
lbry
potentially we do have both of us have
websites that have email sign up
um sheets mailing mailing lists and i
bet if i say that badly
the person who monitors them will text
me here
i'm just going to turn it off airplane
mode so that if i get that wrong they
can correct me and i can
see what the actual correct thing is um
i'm going to put my phone
here so if you go to both both
either of our websites and just sign up
i think it may say
you know sign up to hear when the book
is available for pre-order well our book
is available for pre-order now but um
there's still
potentially reason to get your name into
our system
we have yet to use those lists in any
way and
we promise no spam um so that that's as
good as we have at the moment but we
should do
we should do better we should we should
be more diligent about this
yeah let me just see if um
yeah so far right we are depending on
the fact that we make
very poor villains and that makes us a
little bit hard to throw off these
platforms
yeah yeah yeah yeah it turns out we
don't suck behind the scenes
sorry enemies making their jobs hard
yeah
that's what we do um if we i should
color that zach could you make that uh
timpool one a different color
since i have a harder time when it's in
this framework the one that i've got
highlighted at the moment
yeah um if we are programmed to minimize
senescence
can we hack it positively by having a
sense of purpose
whose primary form may be parental care
tending to our genes
is
is art the extended phenotype of
parental care
a little hard to parse the question but
i think this is
this is echo and i feel like it might be
two questions
um i think the question is about
uh just substituting
uh one kind of productivity for the
standard
biological and i think this is
absolutely true and i think actually
selection has done it at the lineage
level
that it um rewires individuals
to do exactly this and it does so
because lineages in which individuals
are rewired that way
have advantages over lineages in which
everybody is wired for their own fitness
um so yes now
you know art is a little bit hard to
know
yeah yes things within the realm of art
can be
exactly this if you imagine selection at
a lineage level
um and certainly at this stage in
evolution
whether or not it's a historical pattern
it's something we would well we would be
wise to consider doing
yeah this next one i think there's
something interesting here but i don't
think there's enough information for me
to know exactly what
the question is when mcwhorter when john
mcwhorter rebuffed that a
man and a woman meme wagon it reminded
me of a c.s lewis quote about a process
that
will make us into devils i would love to
hear this described evolutionarily
i don't just don't know enough about the
lewis quote to um
to respond yeah but i mean you know we
can infer
that there is certainly something about
mob mentality
and uh witch hunting etc
um which is the result of people
feeling morally justified to go after
other people
so i don't know what the lewis quote is
i'm curious but
uh yeah there are such processes and
we've seen them up close
and it's dangerous stuff
all right um any ideas on why
testosterone levels are plummeting in
men
thanks
was it on our private q a that the
answer to some similar question
ended up being plastics plastics is
going to be part of that that's going to
be a big part of this
yeah um but you know there's lots of
stuff tangled up that was specifically i
think about
women female reproductive success and
birth control and stuff but
right yeah um but i would say look there
you know every so often
you run into a finding that doesn't mean
what you think it means
right like you know cancer rates are
going up are cancer rates going up
because there are more carcinogens
well that's one possibility and almost
certainly true um
it's also true that people are living
longer
right the longer you live the more
likely you ultimately get cancer it's
also true that we've got
fancier more finely honed techniques by
which to
discover cancers many of which we never
would have seen before and the people
living with them wouldn't have actually
had their lives cut short by them
because they were so small and
insignificant
exactly um it's also true that to the
extent that you cure other things you
know
people don't die of gangrene anymore um
if you cure
everything but cancer then we'll all die
of it so you know the fact that it would
be a hundred percent
doesn't mean anything bio cancer it's
going up right because we cured gangrene
right exactly so the point is you got to
start thinking in that way
in order to know whether testosterone
levels plummeting
means something now i think there is a
result that suggests that testosterone
levels are
going down but it's actually hard for me
to fit this question into the rubric
that you just described well
what i was going to point out is one
reason testosterone levels will go down
is
men are living longer and they go down
with eight right so if this is just an
aggregate across the lifespan measure
right okay and i yeah i actually don't
know the data um
i've heard this thing as everyone has
heard but i actually have not looked at
the data
yeah so there's that that's that's a
definite possibility what if
what if they've done it well though what
if they've controlled for that and said
testosterone for men in their 30s is
lower than it was 50 years ago
and it's very tempting to think you know
it's it's a physiological input
but it's also likely to be true that
testosterone
levels are responsive to one's own
perception of their
you know place in a hierarchy or the
need for the characteristics that are
downstream of testosterone so
you know if uh you know if the culture
is
um emasculating in a uh
in a a metaphorical sense then it may be
that the body responds to this feeling
by
you know moving away from testosterone i
don't know
yeah and then to get back to the
plastics question um
there's not too many androgens in the
water supply male steroid hormones
but there are lots of estrogens and
estrogen mimics
and um i wonder and i actually just do
not know the biochemistry well enough to
know if this is even
plausible but because um
[ __ ] which way is it does testosterone
aromatize into estrogen or is it the
other way around
i actually i don't even remember which
direction that goes
um but i i something you know
big black boxes said it right but i
don't remember i said it both ways
though
the second one you said testosterone
aromatizes
to into estrogen anti-estrogen that's
what i want to say
yeah um so you know giant biochemical
black box here
which again if i had time i can go look
at some of the work i did on this in the
early 90s
excuse me
i wonder if um one of the effects of
having all of these
basically of having our systems flooded
with a bunch of exogenous estrogens
uh might in part be sending uh the body
a message
about um not needing to produce as much
testosterone as well
um and i you know that's that's
really imprecise as a prediction given
that i can't even remember the sort of
the fundamental
uh endocrinology at the core of it but i
think there might be something there
okay where are we are elon's companies
game b
that is uh in that their main purpose is
not to make money
yet well i wouldn't think of it that way
those of us who take game b seriously
talk about things that are that have
elements of game b so game b would be
a system it is possible for a project
to have a component of game b but not
all components
um or it's also possible for it to be a
prototype that could have
that could uh mature into something like
a game b
um and i would say um
musk's endeavors certainly
have some elements that lean in this
direction
um they're not alone in that regard but
uh but yes there is something there
there's some some reason to invoke game
b
with those projects um i'll fight you
naked
says the time article proves the
election was rigged
oh goodness um does it prove the
election was rigged
i mean it not not to go all clintonian
but i guess it depends on what your
definition of rigged is
here this is why this is driving me
crazy yeah they're all [ __ ] rigged
they're all rigged right and this is the
point you've made here
i've made it many times they're if
they're not rigged in the general
election
they're rigged in the primaries every
single [ __ ] one they don't want to
risk democracy
they fear it right so
this one was weird right and this
article is strange but you know
to say the election was rigged leaves
the implication
that the outcome that the number of
votes
that biden won and the implication in
the electoral college
um was inaccurate enough to change
the outcome we do not know that
what we know is that there was an
organized effort
to play some game at the same time we
were being told there was no game
but how could anybody believe that there
was no game
right there was a game from the
beginning there was a there was a an
attempt
to remove trump from office from the
moment he took office
it was ongoing right there was an
impeachment
did he abused power enough to be
impeached
yeah i think so but they didn't care
clearly
yeah right they wanted to impeach him
because
it was the thing that they it was the
red meat that they needed to throw to
their constituents
and it was the narrative they needed to
feed so
you know i i i'm having this weird
experience with this thing which is like
okay a lot of people were impressed with
this article
maybe it's super impressive and i'm the
only person who doesn't get it but
you know yes the system is rigged the
whole thing is rigged was the election
rigged
well isn't the impressive i mean i
haven't read it but isn't the impressive
thing about the article that it's
published in time magazine i mean just
like we started off the
first two hours today by saying hey
you know matt ridley and alina chan
actually got into the telegraph
and then there's one in washington post
and like like this is actually hitting
some mainstream
places such that more people are going
to read it and go huh i wonder what that
means
so first of all those are two opposite
things because this article
is triumphalist the time magazine
article is like hey look at all this
cool stuff we did to fortify the
election blah blah blah blah blah it's
proud right it's not the high quality
i don't i didn't i don't know that yeah
no it's it's that which
yes it's freaking alarming but um
the
i i don't know what to do with the fact
that i'm not having the same
reaction as as other people it's but
here's the thing
yeah you often to things that you
experience don't have the same reaction
as other people and then you think and
you think and you think on it
and uh often that is where the insight
happens
so i'm not saying it's gonna happen
right here like that's not that's not
how it happens but
um you know you being thrown
by not having the same reaction to this
article as what
appears to be the reaction a lot of
other people are having hey i would like
caution you that the
the tenor of questions doesn't
necessarily tell you what people
are are thinking and maybe you've maybe
you've had other conversations maybe
you've seen other stuff online but
um that is exactly when there's a
mismatch between what the world seems to
be perceiving
and you go and you specifically go in
and say i am not in any way interpreting
this the way everyone else seems to be
there's something to be seen here
there's something to be discovered
yep could be and no doubt in discussing
it
hopefully i will advance the ball by
pushing other people who are having the
other reaction
in some ways that they wouldn't be
pushed and vice versa but i would just
say
okay that article taken in isolation
alarming in a week
and i did find during our break i did
find the article it was a different
article in which the new york times
proposed
a reality czar but
you know it was right there in black and
white in the new york times
right and they're like honestly no
you know their point is we know that
sounds bad
but hear us out and it's like i had a
conversation with a friend this week
and she said i just feel every day like
asking
are you punking us like seriously are
you punking us right now look
you know i'm not saying there's any
evidence for this but
this kind of derangement of society over
issues this simple right
is somebody doing this to us it's a fair
question
right because it's hard to imagine how
you could get this dumb on your own
right i mean honestly like you know a
reality czar like
that's the thing we're going to shut
down chat because people might say
things that aren't
true those two things in the same you
know week
the same week in which we're talking
about the idea that merit
is racist and therefore we should find
some other thing to
i mean and for the first time in a year
the people who are supposed to be
leading the charge and the
biggest pandemic in living history are
saying well maybe that thing
that we were mocking all year is
possible sure right
exactly the whole thing is so off the
rails that you know
are you know it is some kind of a
psychotic a collective psychotic
break that we haven't figured out how to
um how to grapple with but as far as i'm
concerned
the whole thing you know this is this is
reason decohering and you know it does
not surprise me in the slightest
that um that as i said before everything
up to the limit of the law was done and
probably beyond and
you know what isn't in that article
that's what i want to know
i guess i have to read it
uh where are we at zack you are at
hour and five minutes let us do three
more questions okay shall we
immunologically how do bats differ from
humans
um i don't know the answer to that i
think the answer to that you know i'm
sure there are little differences
i don't know what they are but they're
going to be um
i don't think there's any difference
that there is likely to be
that would be meaningful if i said it
out loud right in other words you're
going to have
b and t cell immunity you're going to
have
you know mammals isn't that old a group
and you're going to have and you know
we're
we're even higher up the tree here
because you know we're talking about
placental mammals
so the immune systems are going to be
very very similar
yeah regarding interspecies altruism
do mammals exhibit this behavior
interspecies altruism to protect
mammalian genes going forward
i'm thinking about cetaceans protecting
humans from sharks humans keeping dogs
and cats domesticated mammals rearing
others
individuals of other species you go man
um
yeah i think so first of all citations
protecting humans from sharks
is not the cetacean is doing humans a
favor it's them spiding the goddamn
sharks which
um now let's put it this way i actually
think something like this is possible it
flies in the face of
standard classic evolutionary uh theory
yep but let's just say
i think you can make you the problem is
the way you want to explain this
is uh group selection and it does not
fly
that way the way the person asks in the
question wants to explain it no the way
one wants to it's just a dirty way to
get there right
it's very kumbaya on the other hand
group selection colon it's very good
hi david sloane wilson
but let's put it this way um
the nice thing one of the many nice
things about the
i believe completely rigorous lineage
way of viewing these processes
is that it allows you to see
responsibly how such a thing could work
for larger scale clades
right in other words
a clade that got through
history by virtue of some kind of
inter-species collaborativeness
is still getting through history which
is the whole point
so anyway i don't know how often it
happens but let's just say
our whole categorization is
broken right and there are ways
there are ways for something to look
like what you've hypothesized that isn't
that that's basically just
reciprocal altruism um or you know which
would be called mutualism when it's uh
between members of a different species
but really we're talking about the same
process
but you yes there is a way for it to
happen how often it happens
i don't think we know final question
what are the likely risk factors and
causes of autism
it's a big question i haven't thought
carefully
enough about it i think i think we could
do an interesting analysis with some
with some time to consider but um
on first pass i will say there's
probably some
um some mechanisms by which it develops
that are
that are biochemical and or genetic but
um
by and large you know get given the rate
of increase that we see
in modernity it's going to be yet
another
again the focus of our book yet another
hyper novel
um set of situations and uh
one thing that we have talked about uh
in the past
is that um strikes us as likely to be a
risk factor
is uh parking your children in front of
screens
especially um and you know it's unlikely
that
these screens wouldn't have these things
but especially screens with human or
humanoid or animal
like critters that appear to be
interacting
but that when the young child tries to
interact with the screen of course the
screen does not interact back
and that this will it seems kind of
obvious
developmentally send a message um that
those things that appear humanoid aren't
necessarily so
and that they keep doing whatever
they're doing even absent attempts at
interaction well it also
it breaks so there's a developmental
feedback that will
set in between actual humans right
where you emote you don't necessarily
know that that's what you're doing but
you emote and the person reacts and you
develop the capacity to send messages in
this way and to the extent that the
thing on the screen looks just like a
person and you emote at it and it's
completely indifferent
it breaks the normal developmental thing
yeah that's better said that's good
i will say there was some interesting
evidence pointing in this direction
years ago it was very odd but there was
a
flurry of interest surrounding a paper
that indicated that autism
was more common in rainy climates and
the
hypothesis which i don't know if it was
tested going forward but the hypothesis
which was all
too plausible was that the rainy
climates were causing
uh more indoor time more screen time for
the kids therefore triggering i don't
think they got to the analysis that we
just delivered but the idea being
that it would bring about something like
that disruption of the developmental
environment so
i guess the last thing i would want to
say is and you know you suggested this
but
autism is liable to be a
garbagey category that the point is it's
downstream of very complex processes
and how many different disruptions are
there that could lead you to have things
that we say oh that's autism
right um so we need to be careful
because it can be
you know uh can be a chemical
and at the same time it can be a
developmental influence
and frankly um the overarching as you
point out the overarching concern
is evolutionary novelty just your child
is encountering a great many things
an ancestor would not have encountered
and some of them have the capacity
uh you know to disrupt a normal pathway
and it could be that the very same
influence
if it had been encountered you know a
month later would have had no
important impact but you know the
opportunity for the disruption was there
the disruption happened at the right
moment
and next thing some cascaded effects
follows from it yep
well i think we've reached the end the
very end
the very very end other than
a few announcements here which are
which are i hope to have my entire voice
back by next week
awesome um join us at our patreons brett
weinstein our heather heing's patreons
for
a whole bunch of interesting stuff
discord server on both private monthly q
a on mine
a couple of conversations on rats the
private monthly q as with both of us
um there is stuff available at the store
which you see on your screen now
store.darkhorsepodcast.org
you can send questions to
darkhorse.moderator
gmail.com you can find clips on the
clips channel and if there's anything in
particular you'd like clipped you can
send that also to darkhorse.moderator
gmail.com anything else
uh achieve greatness that's cheap
greatness yes
eat good food go outside
love those who should be loved oh that's
good yeah love
love only those who should be loved and
everybody else too i guess that's
ruined it i did sorry all right
uh next week i promise to stop ruining
things
all right be well everybody
you